Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at if there
was ever a specific obese woman who inspired
the phrase "It ain't over until the fat lady
sings"
You might think the expression, “The opera
ain’t over until the fat lady sings,”
derives from some stereotypical “fat lady”
singing to close out operas.
In particular, some have theorized that the
expression in question derives from the last
part of Richard Wagner’s The Ring of the
Nibelung (knee-be-loong)), Twilight of the
Gods, where the character of the Valkyrie
Brünnhilde is typically played by a pleasantly
plump woman who closes out the lengthy opera
via a near twenty minute aria.
But none of this is correct.
The exact expression in question is actually
a relatively recent invention, tracing its
origins to the 1970s.
It is commonly credited to Dan Cook, a sports
broadcaster from San Antonio, Texas.
He was reporting on a playoff game between
his hometown Spurs and the Washington Bullets
in 1978 in which the Spurs were down three
games to one.
Seemingly off the cuff, Cook stated: “The
opera ain’t over till the fat lady sings.”
But this, also, is not the true origin of
the exact phrase.
For that, we have to go back to 1976, when
Ralph Carpenter was giving a report on The
Dallas Morning News in March of that year:
"Despite his obvious allegiance to the Red
Raiders, Texas Tech sports information director
Ralph Carpenter was the picture of professional
objectivity when the Aggies rallied for a
72-72 tie late in the SWC tournament finals.
“Hey, Ralph,” said Bill Morgan (Southwest
Conference information director), “this
… is going to be a tight one after all.”
“Right,” said Ralph.
“The opera ain’t over until the fat lady
sings.”"
So while Cook didn’t actually coin the phrase
as is often stated, his utterance did result
in its popularization via inspiring Bullets
coach Dick Motta to borrow the phrase and
repeat it frequently during their playoff
run that year as a sort of rallying cry against
overconfidence.
Motta even had t-shirts made with the expression
on it.
At this point you might be wondering if Carpenter
really came up with the phrase off the cuff
in 1976.
It doesn’t appear so.
You see, “The opera ain’t over till the
fat lady sings,” is just a modern version
of a much older Southern expression, with
the family of expression going all the way
back to at least the 1870s.
For instance, in the October 17, 1872 edition
of The Daily Picayune, it states, “As long
as the organ is playing, church is not out.”
Not literally referring to church getting
out, this saying has the same common usage
as the “opera/fat lady” expression, simply
saying “It ain’t over yet” or, to use
a similar phrase, “Don’t count your chickens
until they’re hatched.”
In 1894, another example is seen expressing
the same sentiment in a report from the August
17 edition of The Fort Worth Gazette,
"The impression is still strong among railroad
passenger agents that there will be further
reductions in the rate to the Washington encampment
of the Knights of Pythias.
“Church is never out till the people get
through singing,” said one of them this
morning, and all of them talk as if they understood
the language of this parable."
In yet another instance, this time in 1896
reported in the New York Tribune, one Chauncey
M. Depew is asked, “Do you think the Governor
still has a chance?”
(referring to Levi P. Morton seeking a presidential
nomination), to which he responds:
"While there is life there is hope.
It doesn’t do to count on anything as a
certainty until all is over.
Church is never out until they stop singing."
The expression became relatively common from
here, particularly in the Southern United
States, and, fast-forwarding a bit through
history, is even known to have been used by
various sports broadcasters in the 1970s.
For instance, in 1974 pioneering female sportscaster
Lee Arthur noted while broadcasting on KDKA,
Pittsburgh during a Rangers / Penguins hockey
match: “Back in Indiana we used to say,
‘The church ain’t over till the singing’s
through.'”
Two years later, in 1976, it was reported
in The Baltimore Sun that the captain of the
Baltimore Clippers team, Fred Speck, said
of his team’s chances, “Church isn’t
over until the choir stops singing.
Anything can happen.”
That same year, in a little obscure work called
Southern Words and Sayings, the first documented
instance of incorporating “fat lady” to
the phrase occurred where it states, “Church
ain’t out ’till the fat lady sings.”
Given the nature of this work, it can be assumed
that this variation was at least reasonable
well-known in certain parts of the South previous
to this documented instance.
(It has also been claimed, though I couldn’t
find any documented evidence, that another
common variation at the time was “It ain’t
over till the fat lady sings the blues.”)
From this, it would seem likely that Carpenter’s
real contribution (if any) to the sentiment
was simply substituting “church” with
“opera,” using the already established
“fat lady sings” variation of the phrase.
Two years later, Dan Cook and then Dick Motta
would borrow the phrase, popularizing the
“opera” version with the masses, and the
rest, as they say, is history.